well europe has come under renewed
criticism over its treatment of migrants
for years thousands of asylum seekers
have been living in
inhumane conditions in greece five greek
islands near the turkish coast have
become known as
hot spots where refugees live in
overcrowded
unsanitary conditions more than a third
are children
mostly without access to education now
the eu says that turkey should take them
in as part of a deal reached with ankara
five years ago
but many experts say that deal is a
human rights
disaster dw's max sander reports on the
situation
on the island of lesbos a prominent
guest at the eu's most notorious
migration hot spots
while eu commissioner ilva johansson
toured mavrovuni camp
in a guarded convoy earlier this week
journalists were given a rare
opportunity to visit the nicer parts of
the overcrowded facility
scenes of women exercising in the spring
sun starkly contrast
these pictures from last winter when
residents had to hold on to their tents
while the sea flooded their homes we
meet joko from the democratic republic
of congo
he tells us he has been here for 16
months
we are living like animals without
documents i've had my asylum interview
already but haven't heard anything since
this is the sad fate we face
more than thirteen thousand people are
stuck in these hot spots on the north
aegean islands
as part of a system designed to help
greece cope with high numbers of
irregular arrivals
as part of the eu's 2016 migration deal
with turkey
greek authorities with eu support have
to examine whether each person arriving
here has a right to asylum
those whose claims are rejected must
return to turkey
and as long as asylum seekers don't have
an answer they can't leave the islands
critics claim this model is simply not
working it creates a
situation of deep injustice because
people are kept in some cases for many
years in the hot
spots and as we've seen the conditions
there
are appalling they're really not
effective and if we look at the court of
auditors reports on the hotspots for
instance they show that they're
extremely expensive and not serving the
original purposes of rapid
decision on cases instead of setting up
appropriate infrastructure to deal with
asylum cases in a swift manner
five years on from when the deal was
signed authorities are operating in
emergency mode
even eu commissioner johansson agrees
this system has to change
i don't want to have hot spots i would
like to have proper reception facilities
where people should not stay for long
and then have a better
return and relocation system we need to
europeanize
migration issue and to stand by each
other
and not leave any member state or island
alone the eu commission has proposed a
new approach to asylum
under which asylum applications would be
processed within days at the bloc's
external borders
but critics fear this might lead to a
situation similar to what we're seeing
today
hot spots all over again
let's bring in francisco brantner she is
a member of the german parliament and
the green
party's spokesperson for european policy
welcome to the program and thank you for
joining us
we've just been witnessing there some of
those terrible conditions for asylum
seekers on lesbos for example
in your view what do you think might
have gone wrong with the hot spot
approach
everything everything has gone wrong
it's terrible that we still
have these really really bad and
unacceptable conditions on the islands
there has been european money going
there it was just
said in the report it's not a question
of adding money to it
it's a political decision by the greek
government
to have terrible conditions on these
islands because they still believe it
will incite others not to come
but we also have other european
countries refusing
to accept a distribution of those living
on the islands right now for example the
german government is accepting some but
very few
only entire you know only when there has
been a crisis we still don't have any
real system
and it's high time to change that and in
fact you've called for a more realistic
approach a more coordinated european
approach to asylum policy what exactly
might that look like and
is it realistic
i think it's important that we do
establish
uh centers where you do people register
people and then you distribute them
across the eu
for checking their asylum status and we
won't be able to do this
at 27. i don't think it's realistic but
i think that it will be realistic to
start with a few
to go ahead and start changing the
system because the current one is not
acceptable and that needs pressure on
the greek government
it needs pressure on europe on some of
the other eu governments and i think you
know
as you said it's not realistic at 27. we
need a coalition of those who are not
accepting any longer to have such
conditions within the eu
what more would you like to see from
from european countries for example from
germany
i want my german government to finally
accept and make possible that those
cities and states within germany that
have said we are ready to take on
people from the greek islands through
bandwidth and back you know to
many many cities who said we are ready
to do this and it's the german
federal government blocking this i don't
understand it i just
want mr seahoof to give this free and to
say if
states in germany are ready to accept
them to help greece
to help these citizens in need then we
should really make this possible
francisca brettner member of the german
parliament and the green party
spokesperson for european policy thank
you
thank you